centuries ago
okay guys you have 90 minutes think
old-school when it comes to telling your
story like when birds were thing Jordan
came to the city of angel Grove to
establish a command center Zordon an
interdimensional being chooses a random
American every city to establish a
command center instead of literally
anywhere else in the world the noble
master sought out six extraordinary
teenagers because six extraordinary
people in their late 20s wouldn't be
angsty enough nor would it hit the
target demographic young heroes could
use their powers to call upon colossal
assault vehicles known as swords woods
or Don and trust this to any human being
at all
he clearly has expansive powers not to
mention access to an army of robots he
should have total control over but
instead he uses emotionally volatile
teens also absorb on arrived centuries
ago does that mean the sword assault
vehicles are old tech or have they been
upgraded through the years or the first
Zords just tricked-out wagons I can't
prove that stock footage but that stock
footage
Kimberly uses her inside voice even
though she's standing near the open door
of an airplane 15,000 feet in the air
when the Red Hot Chili Peppers meet the
Mighty Morphin Power Rangers do you get
the muddy hot Morphin peppers and what
happens when the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles or the Aqua Teen Hunger Force
jump in man so many forename group
orgies so little time Mighty Morphin
point breakers right movie expects me to
believe they can communicate with each
other this easily in a freefall over a
full minute of skydiving bulls that's
angel Grove it's been huge I'm very
disturbed by the fact that there's an
American city the size of Saint Louis
that I've never heard of before in order
to save the Observatory the city of
Angel Grove employs some teenagers to
jump out of a plane with no adult
supervision because even though a bake
sale or a car wash would probably raise
more money it wouldn't be merely as 90s
extreme attention
big father/son characters are extremely
fake wait so any jackoff in town could
sign up for the jump athan did the
skydiving company donate all the
training manpower airplane and other
resources needed for a safe skydiving
experience so teens could feel like
they're saving an observatory because if
not I don't think they raised any money
if anything this event is operating at a
loss this is a pitiful turnout for a
city that size I don't even see any news
cameras Observatory is definitely gonna
shut down or they're dead these two
assholes jump out of a plane without
fully securing their chutes or their
helmets I feel a freeze-frame coming at
any moment followed by the JCPenney logo
accompanied by some late video tape
tracking hey if these kids don't do at
least three cool sports at the beginning
our target audience will not like this
movie we're all of five minutes into
this movie and I've already had it with
the comic relief you should come and
have a look at this cliche whoa did
these construction workers steal their
boss to come up here and take a look at
this just now the whole thing is exposed
already you mean it took until they
completely cleared the dirt off this
thing to tell somebody about it how
about you halt construction and get an
archaeologist instead
apparently there's a smoke machine under
the ancient manhole what do you think it
is a giant plastic Easter egg also even
though these guys have unearthed an
ancient alien artifact this site isn't
crawling with top-secret government
agents erasing people's memories with
laser pointers this guy's Union so he
gets ancient evil electrocution pact
wait I thought sorta and set up his
command center and Angel Grove not on
Tatooine
thanks alpha fine for making no attempt
to sound any different from Johnny five
and including short circuit in your
first line of dialogue even though
Zordon put Ivan ooze in this egg six
thousand years ago the sensors in Zordon
zone system can't handle the evil that
this egg is producing it will be known
as Ivan
okay 90s what the fuck is up with your
obsession with whose you put use in
fucking everything
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles to the
x-files the entirety of Nickelodeon and
that scene in The Little Rascals when
Waldo calls his dad I mean it was
everywhere six thousand years ago since
six thousand years ago was the beginning
of the Bronze Age and the invention of
written language
you'd think archaeologists would have
discovered some evidence of an alien
evil overlord before now too much time
in Egypt not enough time an angel Grove
I guess capable would enslaving the
entire universe fake Wizard of Oz's
mouth doesn't sync up with the speech
even a little a group of young warriors
like yourselves not quite as deep as a
normal in the ground parking garage
though also I guess they parallax his
ass that never fails use extreme caution
Rangers you are dealing with an evil
here this is beyond imagination
including the screenwriters some
otherworldly egg emerges from the ground
and the city of angel Grove sends its
finest security guards equipped with
metal folding chairs after 2,000 years
of searching you are finally where the
were you looking for this egg for 2,000
years the power of this egg obviously
called you here and that's why you're
here now so what were you doing for
2,000 years combing the Earth's beaches
with a metal detector that's what you
say why the fuck is Ivan ooze inside an
egg he doesn't seem like an old vaporous
creature in any way
I guess the screenwriters came up with
so many egg related puns they had no
choice
keep in mind this is all happening in
the middle of a major city even though
it's the middle of the night there
should still be passers-by that would
see this bull like teenagers
I thought about asking what teenagers
smell like but that's the kind of
question that gets you on a special list
also he can smell teenagers above all
the other smells at this construction
site like above the sweaty working man's
stench the teens he talks about just
roller-skated through here briefly you
mean that the six of you are ready to
battle evil in short sweatpants and
vests yes I see that now were these
assholes this late in arriving to the
scene it was daytime when they were
summoned by sword ah they transported to
their headquarters he told them about
Ivan ooze and sent them back and now
it's night and way too late to see what
happened also they were literally in the
area when they transported sword on
didn't show them any pictures or a short
video or even a PowerPoint presentation
nothing he could have simply told them
about this over the phone and told them
to check it out before anything happened
did it look something like this
I haven't decided to assume the identity
of a random security guard even though
he immediately reveals himself acting
were the Power Rangers roll credits why
even do this okay you just electrocute
the entire power ranger team right now
say evil space news beings are no match
for yellow caution tape
god damn it there's no one in this movie
know how nightmares work if you're
succeeding it's not your nightmare when
you can tell your foe let me get the
door before slamming a door at its face
that's not a worthy adversary how many
of these actors considered quitting
forever during the scene this fight
scene wasn't so much choreographed as it
was constructed around all the available
puns in the area flipping when running
would be much more effective you mean
just now
the hoos monsters wait patiently while
the Power Rangers morph mightily our
ranger fighting is 80% jumping before
they were doing normal human karate now
they're doing normal human karate but
with vinyl suits on and now that they
have their vinyl suits on all of their
arm moves are accompanied by swooping
sounds that a charley horse
Joran a sonic even though I haven't been
trapped in an egg for six thousand years
he knows what the Renaissance is
[Music]
during Ivan's time in the egg which
apparently had a link to the outside
world he developed an extreme love for
the Brady Bunch
in fact I'm going to add another 50 sins
for I haven't knowing the stuff he knows
about in this movie you mean flashlight
activating power scope you mean normal
vision but with intrusive graphics also
Jesus Christ can you believe this was a
tentpole summer action movie for Fox
back in 1995 I came out on June 30th
with Apollo 13 and Judge Dredd meaning
they actually thought this was a great
July 4th holiday release and I pity the
poor bastard who watched this
and Judge Dredd over the same week if
they can do this fly weibull's then why
the hell are they even fighting
this is some serious physics defying
nonsense which I would forgive if it
didn't look fake man we owe an apology
to mr. Frese for all those terrible ice
puns he used in Batman and Robin Power
Rangers beat his number by the second
reel of this movie and two years earlier
all in all though despite the fact there
are cheap effects and terrible fight
choreography here these fight scenes are
no less confusing or less satisfying
than the ones in age of Ultron ok the
last time I heard this much swooping I
was watching the video for Michael
Jackson's bad seems like they could have
done this sooner
in fact that feels like the title this
movie should have went with I think it's
the same length maybe even shorter when
you consider syllables also is this some
kind of boomerang sword or is it
sentient enough to fly around the bad
guys like this also did it forget it was
a sword and decide to use a laser to cut
this metal thing down just be a laser
bad guys decide not to move away from
this metal bucket thing even though they
had plenty of time to avoid getting
squashed maybe they couldn't handle any
more terrible puns and decided this is
the perfect time to end it all
you've been like a father to us all
which brings up a solid question do any
of these teenagers have parents are the
Power Rangers just an army of orphan
mercenaries okay well sorry Zordon right
right you are I mean you've had 30
seconds to think about this remember
everyone's died trying this and you
won't have enough power to get back and
all the things that make this trip total
bullsh powers but we're still the Power
Rangers
no you're just Rangers ubi takes a risk
by making basically every other
character the comic relief fam fails
miserably do you know that been in a
completely different location the whole
time I'm going to add two sins for Ivan
creating a bird army with a loogie one
for it happening and two for making me
write it down and you know what three
for making me say it
Lutie goes full Wizard of Oz and
basically does everything except have
you say fly my pretties I bet the actors
in those bird suits paid a lot of money
for a theatre degree he's literally burn
human hybrids are gonna fly to another
planet because gravity and physics
it looks strikingly similar to coastal
Australia and you have no idea where to
go and almost no idea what you're
looking for
good luck I'm going to report the Paris
of angel drone be sure this movie wasn't
written by actual children it seems odd
that the adult alien would refer to all
the adult humans as the parents I was
just thinking
like the time he was in that tube and I
stood there looking at him or the other
time he was in that tube and told us to
go fight someone also in the middle of
this dangerous trip where time is of the
essence I figured I'd grind this
adventure and movie to a halt and think
about stuff sure let's talk about this
now while you're getting your asses
kicked
using Big Bird's name in vain
Kimberly's legs survive this 90's action
heroes are saved by who else Xena
Warrior Princess now that there's only
one competent fighter here to fend off
the bird creatures they revert to the
standard one henchman at a time method
of fighting threat to the birds actually
posed they don't fight so much as give
awkward lap dances go back to wherever
it is you came from she's from another
planet so obviously she has an English
accent the ground is littered with the
bones of those who have tried for it and
failed I don't know if one dead
oversized Lama creature qualifies as
littered but what do I know what's
happened is older he was attacked by
this cosmic being named Ivan ooze try
saying that five times fast without
laughing I'm sure that when you've tried
it
you all believe what exactly are you
supposed to do with it is it food it's
like yak can we use it to make the movie
explain what the man these kids changed
their opinion on who's on a time just
because this evil fellow showed he could
rhyme when did I even find the time to
create a logo and label for zoos and
then find enough plastic jars to
distribute it to all the parents and
Angel Grove dude doesn't need to take
over the earth he needs to be on Shark
Tank this stuff smells so gross here let
me put my hand in it I've always wanted
grimaces semen on my fingers all the
adults in angel Grove decide to touch
the news at the exact same time
instantly creating an army of grown-ups
also movie accurately depicts what an
audience looks like at the 45 minute
mark of this movie while they walk out
on it continues to grow this report is
brought to you by the exposition news
network we tell you exactly what's
happening so the screenwriter can go
grab a drink also alpha 5 gets his TV or
working just in time to see something
that pertains to the story - zero blogs
- construed just from the sheer
stupidity of people to stick their hands
into a strange purple goo for no reason
this asshole still hasn't called the
animal she promised when it was daylight
yes a frog like the one you kiss pure
that gave me a boner and all but how
does it help me fight again
also I like how the Power Rangers
couldn't morph when they got to this
planet did absolutely nothing and then
were given their powers back as if that
problem was never a problem at all what
seemed like an obstacle they'd have to
overcome as quickly swept under the road
by warrior princess magic one step
beyond this plateau and I would begin to
age as rapidly as order how incredibly
convenient or inconvenient however you
want to put it what kind of special
magic power keeps you young in one
geographical location but then ages you
rapidly when you cross into another who
decided on that rule the strength is
inside you trust it speaking of trust
this woman is putting an extreme amount
of trust in these kids even though all
they did was casually name-drop Zordon
she has absolutely no reason to believe
they're trustworthy or can complete this
mission I mean they couldn't even defeat
a few bird people
just as I expected the warrior princess
was an owl oh wait fun who's making this
guy dance made the final cut of the
movie these kids are still standing
around like time isn't of the essence
instead of trying to fill the time with
actual plot in action movie decides to
show the kids just walking around in the
woods for a few minutes people who have
been made unthinking slaves by some
purple ooze somehow need to be reminded
to get back to work Ivan outlines his
evil plan with an eager shot up the hero
kid the cool thing about being eaten by
a skeleton is if it swallows you whole
you just fall out the back of its skull
these kids were just endowed by their
animal spirits or whatever giving them
awesome ninja outfits right did that not
also equip them with any new fighting
abilities how the literal is pre-packed
news coming out of this machine is Ivan
using his magic electric powers to make
bottle tops and stickers but these are
just the parents than there are still
thousands of adults out there who
haven't noticed that a large chunk of
Angel groves population suddenly went
missing
why would he do this he currently has an
army of brainwashed adults that he's
able to control with his mucus and
instead of using this work force to grow
his obsequious army he decides to kill
them all so he and his two monsters have
to do all the distributing themselves
that's not a business it's a hobby I'm
out it sounds awesome but all that
happens is they morph from not having
hoods on to having hoods off bad guys
can conveniently on easily be defeated
by a nearby pool of water
not only is this line not funny it has
no basis in truth whatsoever these dicks
have been fighting all the other Power
Rangers and pretty much exclusively them
so it's not just you you eat goat istic
Oh bastard I'm just gonna 100 cents I
don't think anyone should have any
objections to that right in what just
because he lightly crashed into the wall
he disintegrates good animals the
animals on this pyramid are the same as
the Rangers spirit animals because I
guess this movie was written by very
young children and those are all the
animals they know so the only obstacle
the obstacle that killed so many who
came before it was fighting the handful
of doofuses who lived in the stone door
got it apparently this is the first time
anyone ever noticed a giant Hornet robot
in the middle of the street they seem to
be more of an inconvenience considering
the only thing they're actually doing is
obstructing traffic this giant metal
scorpion hates cars but keeps buildings
remarkably intact bad guys just stand
around while the Power Rangers call for
vehicles from the sky to come down and
help them this takes like a full minute
or so but they just allow it to happen
right in front of them so if these Zords
parked on another planet somewhere and
they fly in whenever they're summoned or
do they just materialize out of thin air
your voice is that remarkably clear
considering their mouths are completely
covered not only as I have been able to
mass produce his own news but he also
found the time to purchase and
distribute matching ponchos for his
mindless parent army you would think
these kids would just be eating pizza
and drinking soda maybe the more
hardcore kids are making out and
drinking beer but no they're just
exclusively eating ivan ooze is snob
this kid whistles and a large group of
unruly children stop what they're doing
to look at him in fact if this news has
brainwashed these teenagers how is this
asshole supposed to snap them out of it
with a simple whistle look it's the way
amazing sort of power shoots these
Rockets and all they do is cause
somebody's 486 to crash when rendering
the effects frog boy waits until he gets
shot before using his electrocuting tone
because starting with this would have
been way too easy what is causing these
Mighty Morphin teens to talk with Pumped
fists all the time this kid knows how to
operate the city's monorail train with
this kind of power why doesn't this dude
one already
whoa somebody call sergeant body-shaming
well I guess the jump-a-thon that
kick-started this movie's plot was all
for naught instead of just doing this to
begin with and easily defeating both bug
monsters thus eliminating the option for
Ivan to possess one they decide to draw
this clipping out destroy more of the
city and give Ivan a fighting chance
this kid knows how to get the train
started but has no idea how to stop it
of course this fucking works now we sure
this kid doesn't have Ivan who's powers
over all the other kids he was able to
convince them to leave they're awesome
no parents party pretty easily to go
rescue all the adults we get Ivan into
the Comets path can a plan count as an
ex marketer because that's what this
feels like the parent should have
totally fallen off at this point right
movie keeps buying time by cutting two
different shots that move the parents
back several feet and these few children
are able to slow a giant mob with
grownups to buy time for this kid to
show up with a fire hose I get that they
just kneed him in the crotch but is that
all the emergency button does raise the
knee by the way no one is operating that
bucket truck I sure am glad this father
and son I didn't care about can have a
happy ending it really made an impact on
the movie's runtime yeah I'm wondering
about that sure Ivan was wreaking havoc
on the city but couldn't they have
dropped off the great power before they
went to go fight him it would have taken
five seconds tops
movie forces me to watch each of these
kid actors one by one try to force out a
tear those who possess the great power
even lazily undoing the predicament that
this movie wrote itself into these
assholes somehow knew standing in a
circle great the power they need to
revive Zordon good for them not only
does the great power allow them to bring
Zordon back to life it also repairs
their entire control center because the
great power is also a great contractor
I'm glad the shiny lights from batteries
not included could find work again no
one seems at all curious about the alien
invasion the mass brainwashing of the
entire city or even the mildest ruction
of that city they're just gonna casually
remember the kid who got the other kids
to not be dicks to their parents and act
like there was nothing colossally
strange about everything else that
happened it's like what you taught me
about martial arts you should have your
hands and feet are also important to
martial arts
we're these two even in this movie stuff
from the cutting room floor or makes it
into a mid-credits scene somehow that's
the band Shampoo doing their song
trouble which I swear will soon lapse
into the b-52s Love Shack at some point
but never does
not crazy argue ever since cinemasins
began the most requested thing has been
TV since and now it's a reality click
the link in the description below to
check out and now the audio outtakes
[Music]
who are you there are some who call me
Tim there beyond the new yellow jungle
is the money
[Applause]
new recruit Joker products with a new
secret spot it's really yeah isn't it
great we could get in big trouble I know
I wonder if it's brains are still in
there inconceivable you keep your center
forth I don't think I miss what you
think it is well sir there's nothing on
earth like a genuine bona fide
electrified six-car monorail when I say
monorail what's it called
that's right monorail
[Music]